hello everyone I'm delighted to have
commissioner King with me who will
present to you the assessments of member
states national the Member States
national risk assessments when it comes
to security of 5g networks and the floor
is yours Commissioner once right okay a
little bit about a bit about the work
we're doing on on 5g each time there's a
sort of step forward big step forward in
technology there's a scramble to get to
the forefront to get the most for your
economy for your society and the deep
your standing in the world and this is
no different it's no different around 5g
there's the additional interest this
time of security because national
security economic security security of
our societies is on the line as well
this isn't a race where you want to be
too far back in the field and across
Europe I think there's been a sort of
growing awareness of how important it is
to secure our critical digital
infrastructure from cyber attacks
espionage or the hospital interference
from the question of force transfers of
technology against a changing global
geopolitical backdrop and so we took the
initiative to suggest that on this
question of 5g it was better to act
together as Europeans to identify and
mitigate potential weaknesses and
vulnerabilities which could have an
effect on how that critical digital
infrastructure was going to work and
that was the thinking behind the
recommendation that we published back in
March which set out a European approach
to protecting 5g security endorsed
supported by the European Council
the European Parliament because this
time it's more than just updating the
way your phone works it's not like 3G or
even 4G it's a revolution because it is
going to be the backbone of our digital
connectivity consumer services industry
critical services all parts of how we
live our daily lives it's going to be
the plumbing of our digital societies
and like all plumbing like all pipes
when it comes to installing it you want
to get it right first time indeed across
Europe the digital plumbers are already
hard at work the license auctions are
ongoing and the deployment of the first
5g networks is is is happening on the
ground in some of our cities and whereas
with the earlier generations 2 3 even 4G
price was a key criterion at this time
with 5g we want to put security squarely
at the heart of decision-making this
need for sort of a collective approach
collective action given that we're
talking about European infrastructure
was at the heart of the recommendation
which set out as you remember a three
phase process to get all Member States
working together to identify the risks
to formulate mitigation strategies to
share those to arrive at an eu-wide risk
assessment and a toolbox of responses
what we're doing today is marking the
end of the first phase of that process
which was Member States undertaking to
carry out national risk assessments to
identify technological risk and
vulnerabilities in different parts of
the future network core and radial as
well as vulnerabilities arising from the
applicable legal regime and other supply
chain risk factors in potential
suppliers
and to look at their first mitigation
measures as of right now standing in
front of you 24 of the member states
have submitted their full risk
assessments and we're expecting to
receive the remaining four very shortly
this works been done jointly by the
member states together with the
Commission and our EU agency for
cybersecurity in a dedicated group of
cybersecurity experts across from across
the EU and together today with
Commissioner Gabriele I want to welcome
the progress that we've made so far
it's an Acheson start but we need now to
continue to build upon it we're going to
begin the next stage in the process
analyzing together the risk assessments
that have been submitted by the member
states using them to draw up an eu-wide
risk assessment prioritizing the most
sensitive and vulnerable aspects of 5g
networks across Europe and we'll do that
by the beginning of October meanwhile of
course some action is already security
action is already being taken at the
national level and and we welcome that
in France legislation on network
security is being discussed by the
National Assembly and the Senate
including the proposal floated there of
prior authorizations and in the UK a
government review is planned to provide
an overview of the risks arising from
telecoms equipment supply chains and
help set objective security requirements
on vy-jee
in October we will come again and will
report on the progress that has been
made by that stage and at the same time
we'll be launching the third stage in
this collective work to develop by the
end of the year a toolbox of appropriate
effective and proportionate risk
management measures that can be taken at
both national level and together at the
European level to mitigate security
threats and ultimately to develop common
minimum standards for the cyber security
of 5g networks across the EU as we've
said before say it again today we're
doing this because it's in our European
interests to do so not because someone
else has asked us to or to target
particular services or suppliers at the
outset because of what is at stake for
European networks we need to look
together at the possible risks and
vulnerabilities work out how best to
manage and mitigate them and if
necessary reach a view on whether
particular products services or
suppliers are sufficiently safe for us
want for us to want to use them in
building these future networks thank you
thank you very much Krishna King so now
we have time for a few questions and we
have also experts in the room in case
you have questions that are more of a
technical nature let's start with the